so what I want to do here is have a
quick discussion about spider wind and
the reason why is that while I am hoping
that at the end of this video you'll
have a strong understanding of her
character leading into the events of the
spider verse story from Secret Wars the
significance of the death of the
original gwen stacy in 1973 as well as
the original spider-verse event are
discussions that we've already had on my
channel so spider-gwen actually comes
out of the original spider-verse event
in a story called the edge of
spider-verse which served to introduce a
series of various versions of spider-man
and spider-woman from alternate
realities set in the earth 65 universe
during a 2014 interview with Newsarama
creator Jason Latour had stated that
spider Guin was originally supposed to
be a one-off who appeared only in the
context of the original spider-verse
story by Dan Slott and was never meant
to be a sensational hit because gwen
stacy was the first major love interest
of spider-man and because her death in
1973 by writer gerry conway assured in
the Bronze Age of comics which saw
darker stories while Mary Jane Watson
picked up the slack and was written in
as Peter Parker's new love interest
until the events of one more day and the
back of everyone's mind was a
recognition of how important to death of
one Stacy truly was as a result since
the goal of the edge of spider-verse was
to bring and various versions of
spider-man that had appeared on
everything from in continuity stories
like superior spider-man and Doctor
Octopus to out of continuity stories
like what a spider-man maintained the
Enigma force Jason Latour was granted
permission to ask and answer the
question what would have happened if
Gwen Stacy were bitten by a radioactive
spider
instead of Peter Parker using this as a
jumping-off platform and edge of
spider-verse issue number two spider
Quinn's origin is given over the course
of a single page and stating that a
radioactive spider had bitten Gwen Stacy
rather than Peter Parker with her father
George Stacy maintaining his rule as a
chief of police in this reality while
Gwen Stacy adopts a mantle of Spider
Woman and becomes a hero the bully Peter
Parker grants himself powers by
injecting himself with a serum but ends
up becoming the lizard instead well this
would go on to see a battle take place
between the two that would have Peter
Parker died as a result of his exposure
to the serum with Jay jonah Jameson
still heading up the Daily Bugle
he used his role to launch a campaign of
propaganda against spiders win that
resulted in society turning against her
with the police attending to arrest her
for the murder of Peter Parker
while the conclusion of this story would
go on to see her injured
alongside the multiversal spider team
during the events of spider-verse which
served as a way for Marvel to eliminate
all versions of spider-man except for
those they wanted to keep at the
conclusion of Secret Wars following the
series end spider Gwyn was rolled over
into a 5 issue series of her own under
the writing and art of Jason Latour and
Robbie Rodriguez respectively which came
to a conclusion with the launch of
Marvel's Secret Wars event over the
course of this story Gwen Stacy's whole
reality was fleshed out and telling us
that Matt Murdock works as the
right-hand man of the kingpin in this
continuity rather than being a hero Mary
Jane Watson is alive but had no previous
relationships with Peter Parker and
instead as a lead singer of a band
titled the Mary Jane's with Gwen Stacy
acting as a drummer and Uncle Ben and
Aunt May are both alive but remained in
grieving over the loss of Peter Parker
and questioned the propaganda of Jay
jonah Jameson in addition to this the
main focus is spidered when solos series
was less about her battles with villains
like the vulture and more about how she
viewed the death of Peter Parker because
Peters transformation into the lizard
was due to a misguided attempt to become
an equal to Quinn Stacy
his death in turn provided the basis for
spider-gwen to maintain her role as a
hero but also established an inner
struggle and that Peters death was
constantly used by both the media and
the press to drive public hatred for
Gwen Stacy this combined with the fact
that Gwen had no true superhero allies
meant that within the realm of her own
continuity there was no evidence to
suggest that the Avengers or the x-men
existed making her a singular entity and
completely alone furthermore unlike
other stories leading into the start of
seeker wars like the death of Deadpool
or the last day's line including the
Silver Surfer and Loki spidered when
solo series did not see a conclusive and
regarding the destruction of the
multiverse and instead it was announced
by Marvel that her home reality of Earth
65 would continue to exist and that she
would remain a major figure in the
all-new all-different marvel lineup by
jumping into various continuities for
adventures with other spider related
characters in addition to her own while
this announcement left many fans
confused and that Secret Wars was
expected to see the total collapse of
the multiverse with only battleworld
remaining as of this moment Marvel has
not provided fans with any explanation
of how her universe survived as such
once we get into the secret war
spider-verse event will find that her
story along with spider UK spider-ham
and others simply just picks up with her
arrival
on banner world and attempt to
understand everything that's going on
with that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end and I will catch
you guys later peace